the phillies will bestow
our highest honor
upon one of the greatest
to wear a phillies
uniform roy halliday
amassed remarkable accolades in his four
seasons with the phillies the phillies
officially retire
roy's number
which means
no
member of the phillies
will ever again
wear the number 34. and there's zach
wheeler's numbers right there he leads
the national league in innings pitch
with 147 and
way ahead in strikeouts he's leading at
170 his closest competitors at 160.
so he's making a run here for his 10th
win and also a run he can pitch well
down the stretch he would be a strong
consideration before cy young award got
that one in it'll go down the right
field line that's going to be a base
head rolling into the corner harper goes
over to get it and into second base with
a stand-up double first hit of the
series demo gets it and that's what the
mets needed to kick this ball game off
he just goes with a fastball at 99.
that's a good choice
first strikeout for will dominic smith
is the batter
and smith hits one out towards center
jankowski is there well they swung early
it took 11 pitches
there was a double
and wheeler is out of the top of the
first and there is taiwan walker's
numbers
first time all-star this year but the
second half has uh
been a disaster so far for him he needs
to really pitch a good ball game segura
starts play today tied for fourth in the
national league and hitting at 308.
segura sends one of the air out toward
left field smith's going back it's gone
and what a reaction by sigour as he's
going up the first base line it's
one-nothing phillies
he did not miss that a four-seam
fastball
obviously where he liked it that is now
the eighth home run allowed by walker in
his last 15 and a third inning
pitch swinging of drive right field it's
pretty well hit good florida going back
to the corner looks up and that ball is
gone
opposite field jt real muto
it's his 13th of the season
second solo shot here in the first it's
two nothing fills
the 0-1 a curve ball popped up by miller
towards shallow right moving in now onto
the infield dirt mcneal he makes the
two-hand catch to retire the side he
allows two solo home runs in the first
inning two hits nobody left one out
nobody on michael conforto coming up
wheeler shakes off the sign now has the
one he wants and the 2-2 pitch
swinging a ground ball roll to the right
side sigur to his left he's got it
slipped a little bit regains his footing
throws to first in time conforto is out
just a roar with every with every out i
know like it's a different
completely different going on right now
here at citizens bank park here's the 02
pitch swing as he struck him out high
heat and vr down on strikes second
strikeout for winter there's a one two
three second that'll bring up taiwan
walker the 0-2
and a swing of the miss he got him third
strikeout for wheeler he's now retired
eight in a row after the lead-off double
by nemo and the pitch he swings and
slices at the left williams backing up a
few steps he will make the catch
and that will retire the side as the
mets go in order one two three inning
and that's nine in a row sat down by a
wiener repeat today the strikeout in his
first at bat in the first inning
swinging a bouncer back towards the
mound we had her bare hand grab off the
back of the hill he'll throw it to first
what a play
you may not see a pitcher make a better
play
something tells me that's going to be
the play of the game the defensive
player of the game wow boy what a
athletic play up over the top of the
mound landing down on the back side of
the mound so two gone and here's dominic
smith swinging a miss
great slider there to put away smith
nasty there's number four and that's 12
straight set down in order by zach
leader
is up grounded out his first time up 12
in a row retired by wheeler
chopped up the middle second baseman
segura up with it
is not running let's say he hurt himself
well now the throw goes to first he
definitely grimaced after he swung the
bat baez hit the ball off the plate and
then winced and then reached back to
grab around his his hip or his
midsection he
was kind of yelling as he was swinging
as he was finishing his swing i mean it
grabbed him immediately
whatever it is and now he's back in the
clubhouse
swag and a miss he hasn't thrown many
curveballs today he's relied on the
fastball more than anything else there's
number five for wheeler zach wieder
grounded back to the mound his first
time up does square
tried to drop it did plays at second
base
and they turned the double play good
defensive work right there by the mets
the attempted bunt ends up being a
double play and gets walker out of the
inning phillies lead it to another the
white sox have won more games at home
than any other team in the american
league 38.
who do you think has more wins at home
in the national league team you'd guess
colorado that one down to first nice
stop made walker to cover and he's able
to get it down he goes
is he all right yes he is and took the
slip there long as we got the throw over
to him had to reach back a little bit to
get it nice play by pete
diving in the hole there so two up two
down and that will bring up bryce harper
in the air to left field dominic smith
is going back and he's going to be a
spectator
on office and field solo home run for
bryce the phillies add to their lead
it's three nothing here in the bottom of
the sixth inning phil's lead has won
three to nothing wheeler in control
going to the seventh
swing of the foul tip seven strikeouts
for wheeler he has just been comfortable
today the way he's pitching weider with
the wind-up and the one-two pitch to
smith swinging a miss he struck him out
breaking ball got him in zach wheeler
with his eighth strikeout of the
afternoon
he has retired 21 mets in a row
well zach wheeler
in command keith well those 21 straight
batters well that starts in the first
inning nemo led this game off with a
double and that's 21 straights cents not
a walk
a strikeout per inning last inning in
the seventh he got two strikeouts
swinging a miss
a high fastball
that is strikeout number nine
talk about cruise control man and the
pitch mccann swings hits it in the air
to right center harper to his right is
there he's got it zach weider eight
innings on the hill today he is allowed
only one hit he's been just flat out
brilliant
zach wieder working on a one-hit shutout
he gave up a hit to the first batter of
the game
and has allowed only one other base
runner since the wind up by weider in
the 1-2 pitch swinging and miss he
struck him out there's number 10 on the
day for winter as pallar goes down on
strikes now the pitch to alonso
the phillies have swept out the new york
mets
a complete game shot out
by zach wheeler who scattered only two
hits
on an afternoon when the phillies
honored roy holiday and retired as
number
34. zach wheeler put together
a roy holiday-esque outing today